and now true love stories from women
just like you I met Stephen at at Barnes
& Noble's which seems retro I know but I
was like carrying this big stack of
books and he bumped into me like we're
in some sort of romantic comedy in the
books spill everywhere and he helps me
pick them up and I just knew how I met
Richard haha my sister set us up she
knows me so well and you know she was
right Richard knew me well too
it was actually a perfect match I met
Mike when I was walking down the street
and he went yo that ass is fat and um I
was like this and he was like that is
and I walked back toward him and he
asked me to put my number in his phone
immediately so I did it was beautiful
what was your first date like it was
actually hard to schedule our first date
because Stevens a doctor a surgeon so I
surprised him at the hospital for lunch
and I just couldn't let him go back to
work he was too great to let get away he
came over and he cooked my sister and I
dinner duck for three people very hard
to do and it was delicious and I
couldn't imagine a more romantic night
on our first date we just got in the
back seat of my Conda and just got it in
like we just got it in all night until
the cops came and moved us from the park
to which my killed the police hint we
just ran and ran it was adorable
what's the sweetest thing he's ever said
to you the sweetest thing that Steven
ever said to me was that when he first
saw me he never expected to see me every
day for the rest of his life but he
right he didn't actually say it to me he
said it about me to my sister I
overheard he said that I was the nicest
girl he's ever met I'm sorry
the sweetest thing Mike ever said to me
was I want to [ __ ] you so hard that you
scream and I just want to take my put it
and you're out of it and you're out of
it and you're out of it and I want to
and I love you that's not a true love
story that's disgusting I'm so sorry are
you okay that is disrespectful no it's
not it's how we fell in love why is she
even here that's horrible all for true
love stories that is gross no I that's
what it's how I found love I'm fine it's
how we ladies ladies
calm down everyone deserves to be here
so let's talk about marriage
oh well Stephen and I haven't actually
tied the knot yet because through a
series of miscommunications he thinks
I'm a stalker but you can't stalk
something that belongs to you doesn't
make any sense
he'll come around well it actually
didn't work out for me and Richard he
ended up marrying my sister which is
fine because I'm an aunt now well Mike
and I have been married for ten years
have two kids and a house on the
countryside oh this is him calling me
now hey Mike did you get the milk honey
and I'm just sitting here with some
lonely ass [ __ ] shooting a specialist
something like that yeah
I don't know one's a psycho and the
other one slept with her sister it was a
miscommunication or any of you or any of
you guys like available to like get
coffee after this or and this has been
true love stories